це все що залишилося від готелю в якому
були розміщені українські біженці в
містечкундорф поблизу узбережжя
Балтійського моря на півночі Німеччини
будівля практично вщент вигоріла Але на
щастя 14 мешканців та троє
співробітників гуртожитку врятувалися
є буквально годину тому з ними
поспілкувався кого зміг знайти на місці
всі в принципі доволі спокійні
шок вже в принципі минув
почуваються добре проблем зі здоров'ям
немає
але переживають з приводу документів
якщо німецькі документи ми відновимо
доволі легко і ми вже отримали підтримку
від нашого округу В цьому плані
то з українськими документами можуть
бути певні складності
будемо співпрацювати з нашим посольством
наскільки вони зможуть нам допомогти і з
відновленням цих документів
є родини в яких документи були знищені
або як мінімум невідомий стан документів
бо не всі кімнати були зруйновані Якщо
так ззовні дивитися
деякі кімнати ще залишилися але про стан
всередині ми не знаємо бо пожежники
всередину не пускають
занадто небезпечно для здоров'я можливі
обвали і так далі
ми виходимо з того що документи просто
згоріли бо на даний момент ніхто не може
точно сказати
хтось точно вам сказати
основна версія причини пожежі підпав
напередодні займання поліція вже
приїжджала сюди оскільки невідомі
намалювали на дверях будинку свастику що
заборонено в Німеччині Кримінальний
кодекс передбачає грошовий штраф або
позбавлення волі строком до трьох років
і хоча й обійшлося без жертв регіональна
та Федеральна Влада коментують пожежу
вкрайрізку
у разі якщо підозри щодо підпалу
підтвердиться це має мати конкретні
наслідки тому що ми хочемо дати притулок
людям які були змушені попри свою волю
тікати зі своєї батьківщини вони без
задоволенням продовжували Мирне життя у
себе на батьківщині як це можемо
дозволити собі ми але якщо люди змушені
тікати Ми хочемо надати їм притулок і я
маю чітко сказати розпалювання ненависті
та насильство проти біженців
неприпустимі і будуть припинятися але
для людей які пережили це вночі Це
катастрофа
не менш жорстко висловилися і міністрка
внутрішніх справ Німеччини Ненсі фезер
на полях зустрічі міністрів країн ЄС
щодо підпалу гуртожитку для біженців Я
глибоко вражена і особливо якщо
задуматися про те що йдеться про людей
які щойно втекли до Німеччини з України
рятуючись від смертельної небезпеки яка
їм там загрожувала І як це для них
раптом наразитися на смертельно
небезпеку тут у Німеччині мене це
глибоко шокує і тому нині наша
найголовніше пріоритет якнайшвидше
розслідувати обставини подій
місцева Влада вже розселила всіх
українських біженців на новому місці до
приїзду пожежників співробітники готелю
та перехожі намагалися боротися з вогнем
але без успішно дах будівлі обвалився
залишилися лише стіни цього літа у
будівлі колишнього готелю розміщувалися
до 170 українських біженців але пізніше
їх розселили по інших будинках
».»
і в фінансовому плані фінансовому плані
і У плані матеріальному
як воно нас називається ЗАГС
в принципі люди дуже перейнялися нашою
бідою і з усіх боків намагаються
поки що історія з такою пожежою єдиний
випадок загалом німці привітно
ставляться до біженців з України і
допомагають чи можуть проте оглядачі
Припускають що прибуття в Німеччину в
російських так званих уклоністів та
їхніх родин може поселити конфлікти між
мігрантами російського походження та
українцями